[Music]
so
colin unfortunately was unable to make
his flight um but it looks like we got
the video
working so colin i'm gonna go ahead and
hand it over to you
great thank you very much so
i'm going to start by saying thank you
to i i assume there's some people in the
audience so thank you very much
i also want to thank our studio both for
inviting me
and also for allowing me to do this via
video conference
so they're very amenable to helping me
out
and i also want to apologize because our
studio didn't quite figure that there's
no one here to tell me to be quiet so
i'm going to aim
for around about 19 minutes but there's
no one in front of me to tell me to sit
down and shut up although i suppose you
could walk out
so a bit about me so my name is colin
gillespie
and i got roped into writing this book
with robin a few years ago
on efficient r programming and i also
co-founded
the company jumping rivers so we've got
a little stall
at the conference which since i have not
seen any other stalls in the conference
as i'm in newcastle i'm sure it's the
best stall there so
please drop by and say hello to the
folks there
so what i'm going to be talking about
is a hackathon that we participated in a
couple of years ago
so this is the northumbrian water
innovation festival
so this is an event that's held every
year
so it's held last year and it's going to
be held again this year
and it's got the word innovation in it
because the government in the uk
said to water companies you have to be
innovative and the best way of
demonstrating innovation is to have a
festival with the word innovation
so this festival runs around about july
and it's
quite a big deal so it runs for the
entire week
there's round about 15 to 20
hacks some of them are data so it's the
one i'll be describing
and on the other end of the spectrum
there's more engineering about designing
widgets and robots and
things to detect or help the water
network
so the way the week was structured
was those two days of background so
monday and tuesday there was a series of
seminars series of lectures
from different people in the water
organisation
telling the participants what was going
on
then on the wednesday and on this
thursday there was
the two hacked days that we were
involved in
and there's around about 10 teams in
total
okay so there's 10 teams and
for each of the 15 to 20 hacks so it's
a big event so we were competing against
another of nine teams in the event
the goal of this hack was to reduce
leaks by 20
i have to be honest i'm currently
sitting in newcastle and england i'm
looking outside
and it's rather wet and damp and i'm
wondering
why this was a goal but this was a goal
they wanted to reduce leaks
so that was what we were aiming to do
so what we were given was data
lots and lots of data so on the
wednesday
we were given access to an azure drive
in the cloud
okay and inside this is your drive
there's render bits of
five to eight gigabytes worth of data
there's some spatial data so
northumbrian water
is has two sites in the uk one up by the
border
in northumbria in england and then down
in the south okay so sort of two regions
and we have spatial data on that
we had time series so with data on
sort of 15 minute intervals we had data
on hourly
weekly monthly intervals with lots of
different types of time series
with all the fun you could imagine with
that
we ugly leakage estimates so how much
water was actually
lost due to leakage we had flow rates
so in the uk you can imagine how
the waters of authority of the water
water companies have evolved over the
last few decades
and we have something called the dma so
dma is a district
needed area and it's a collection of
of zones of postcodes some are quite big
some quite small
and the flow rate is just how much water
is passing through
with how much water has been used by
people we've got the reported leaks
uh it's basically an excel spreadsheet
with some dates
times postcodes and what the person said
over the phone
we've got pipe size so that was
measurements in metric
so centimeters millimeters imperial
uk imperial us imperial roman you name
it we had those in sizes
with pipe location that was more uh
an indication rather than an exact
measurement
again pipes have been laid over the uk
for
decades so they knew there was a pipe on
this road
somewhere on this road and they just
hope for the best
we've got pipe type so you've got
plastic you've got metal
tonsil is also asbestos which have to be
honest worried me at some point
but asbestos we were told it was fine as
long as no one drills into it so
we're all safe we've got social data
that's basically saying you know who's
living in the area uh
is it students families is it business
what sort of mixture
we've got weather rain sun
uh not so often but how much rain we've
got
how much business you know what sort of
businesses are nearby what the usage
and then we've got stuff and what i'm
guessing is someone had a week to put
this data together
the first four days they got all the
stuff in the on the right and then they
spent
the last day just putting in other stuff
and i can't remember what the other
stuff was but it's just
general stuff that might be interesting
so this is what we
had and the problem set up
that we were given is a very
sort of standard i would say sort of
machine learning framework
okay so we've got all this data all that
all the data that you'd think
would give you an insight to leakage
okay and we've got all the previous
results
so we've got leakage from the past of
two three five years we've got
covariates or predictors that we think
would be useful
so weather businesses
pipe type pipe size intuitively if you
think if the pipe was older then it
might break
intuitively you think well if a pipe is
made of lead then that's more likely to
have a leak than a pipe made of plastic
okay and so we're sort of led up to this
very sort of classic machine learning
uh problem of lots of data now put it
into your computer turn the handle
and try and predict what's going to
happen and in my head
i had this amazing algorithm
that would tell someone the precise
coordinates of where the next sleep was
going to happen
and engineers would rush out and fix the
leak before anything would happen that's
that's why i thought would happen
so this is me approximately likeness
and i worked hard all day right so this
is a wednesday
and i started coding about quarter past
nine in the wednesday so just got the
data and i
opened up that the folder and i looked
at
it and i automatically went to work
right so i was a d
player machine hardly would have been
proud okay that this was
amazing you know it turns out
that there's multiple ways of spelling
dma you think there's only one way of
spelling dma
but they spelt dma multiple times so
there's lots of left joins right joins
every join you can imagine i even did
some ai
or regression as i like to call it so i
did some regression i even did some
boosty baggy tree things you know to try
and predict what was happening
you know i was working hard all day you
know i was you know i've seen what was
told
this is seb uh and exactly like this
and seth had a different strategy so we
were in the same team so seb is also in
the booth
uh jumping rivers in san francisco so
please go and embarrass him about this
so seb spent all day drinking coffee
and seba hobnobs as well and so if you
don't know what hobnob is a top-class
biscuit
made in the uk
and sembas questions so in this room
there were 10 teams
and then there were a bunch of tables
where people from northumbrian water
where they are ready to answer questions
and there were some people who were
engineers there were some people who
were sort of
in charge of the analytics some people
who are in charge of customer service
just you know people on tables who are
waiting for questions
so steve would walk around drinking his
coffee eating his hobnobs and
and having a nice jolly old time while i
was working hard
and i was vexed i have to be honest okay
so i was doing all the work
and i wanted to eat hob knobs and i
wasn't getting very many hobnobs
i was drinking lots of coffee
and if i'm being truthful i sort of
started jumping rivers to avoid doing
work you know that's that's what all
founding a company is it's about skiving
from work and
well i seem to be doing lots of work
concepting to be wandering around
doing no work whatsoever
so do you remember back at the start
the goal of the hackathon was to reduce
leaks by 20
and that's sort of an obvious thing you
know who wouldn't want to reduce leaks
by 20 percent
but a more obvious question or a less
obvious question is why
you know why 20 you know why reduce
leaks you know is a big problem
and after chatting with a few people
sev found out and essentially they get
charged a lot
okay so they're wanting to reduce leaks
because they're going to be charged an
awful lot of money
and next year they're going to be
charged even more money
and the year after that they're going to
be charged even more money again
so each year they're going to get
charged more and more money for having
leakage
so the goal wasn't to reduce leaks by 20
percent
the goal was really to reduce the amount
lost due to leakage
and they're both similar ideas
but if at the end of the year you had 10
000 leaks but lost
very little water that solves the second
one but not the first one
and that's what they're wanting they're
wanting to reduce the amount lost due to
leakage
didn't really care about leaks it's just
the overall amount
so that's the first thing second one is
how do you estimate leakage now in the
uk
you pick up a newspaper and you read
something like the amount lost
due to leakage you know was 5 323 liters
and 3 teaspoons and you think they've
got that measured you know that's
accurate you know lots of decimal places
know exactly what's going on right this
isn't made up
well what happens in practice is you
have a dma
so dma is just a collection of zones so
postcodes
again some are quite big and the thought
process goes well
we know how much water is going into the
dma we know how much water is going out
that's how much was being used and well
no one would use water at three o'clock
in the morning
so any water being used at three o'clock
in the morning must be a leak
which isn't the most precise of
measurements when you think about it
over the course of two seconds and
northumbrian water know this
right they know this it's not a surprise
to know this measurement is
shall we say noisy or imprecise
there's nothing they can do about it and
we're currently working with another
company
to actually measure soil temperature and
do a bit of prediction
but what we have on that day is that's
the column that says leakage you know
it's the minimum flow rate at 3 o'clock
in the morning
would you believe that in new year's day
the
the leakage goes through the roof turns
people up at three o'clock in the
morning
so that's what they have what do you
need to fix leaks
well you need an engineer and you need
data
okay so the engineer is obvious right
you need someone to go out there
probably in a van with some tools to fix
a leak
what data do we need well
when an engineer goes out so they're
told there's a there's a lake at
this region well they want to know how
much water flow rate how much water is
being used
what is the pipe type right is it steel
is it plastic is it asbestos
uh what's historical leakage you know
was there someone in the team that went
there last week
and you know perhaps it's the same thing
again
what's the weather you know is it sunny
is it raining
you know they sort of need to be able to
predict this because that could cause
problems
traffic allegedly they're not allowed to
just dig up roads when they feel like it
and so if it's a main road they they
have to
sort of schedule that at night time
crime
do they need to bring a friend to watch
the van when they're going looking for
leaks
and this takes them two hours per day to
get this information
so every single day an engineer walks in
and they say there's a lake
at this area and they spend two hours
getting all this information
all this information that we've just
been given for the hack
there's 35 engineers engineers aren't
cheap
and currently they have every morning
two hours
35 engineers spends trying to get all
this data together
so our solution is not to try and
predict leaks when i say hour this was
seb solution to be perfectly honest
but i'll go for hour now our solution is
not
to try and predict where leaks are going
to happen but to reduce engineering time
we can get that two hours down to about
10 or 15 minutes
it's just giving them the data that they
need and this is
relatively easy and it's definitely
doable right
there's not a sort of r squared or
predictive value or anything like that
it's just about
they have data in one place we're
wanting to make it accessible and
another
so this we can definitely do
now we're now on day two of the hack
right so and and then on the second half
of the day we have to do a presentation
of what we've built
so we've got half a day to do an app and
there's myself instead
so what we need to do is we need to
decide what we're going to make
and decide what to bluff or lie or
pretend or whatever you want to call
so for example if we can demo a single
dma
we don't need to show two three four
five we can do one we don't need to do
more
if we can display pipe location we don't
need to
tell them about pipe type that's obvious
you know we must be able to do it
okay so we decided what to make of water
block
so this is a screenshot of the winning
app this first screenshot
contains lots of bluffing so for example
in the top left hand corner
there's a little person that indicates
we've got authentication
we can do authentication we do
authentication for our customers
we did not do authentication on that
half a day
we've got some high priority dmas
all bluffed we can do that we didn't
need to do that in a day
here we've got a screenshot of what an
engineer could possibly see
so this was a long a long sort of column
of different graphs and different data
the first couple of graphs were nice and
quizzy and interactive
the less the the last few graphs were a
bit more static in nature
and if you look at that little sort of
blue slider
when that was clicked on there the graph
was going gray and that was indicating
that it
wasn't going to be part of an overall
report the engineer would take a
question
also an idea about taking a picture and
then being able to upload it onto the
app
again we didn't have we didn't do this
it was just an indication
and this was all done using lots of deep
player uh gg plot
shiny app and all done in half a day
because we had today more
so the app is now being used in
production i'm the second person on the
right
sort of the tall baldi chat and i would
love to show you
screenshots but because it's got
national infrastructure data
it's got the locations of pipes we can't
just sort of show
screenshots easily so that was when we
won it two years ago
we also won it this year as well uh so
sorry for bragging
but we've won this year's hackers on as
well and we also won that one as well
so i'm not really sorry at all about
bragging i'm not just bragging
completely
so summary
it's obvious but think about your
problem and if someone told me before
the hack
i would say of course you think about
your problem but i really didn't i
jumped in with both feet
i was i'm good at deep planner i'm good
at r i'm good at you know
building models and i went straight for
that
and that's not the best way you know
talk to people
ask them what the problem really is
also don't send me to hackathon without
others so the one hackathon that we've
lost
is the only one i've been to by myself
so it's somewhat embarrassing
so i'm now in this strange situation
where if the team going to hack
i'm not sure if i want him to win or
lose because yeah
anyway so thank you very much for
listening uh sorry i i couldn't join you
over in san francisco it's really
painful watching twitter
and just seeing all this isn't our
studio or conference absolutely
wonderful
so it's painful over in newcastle and by
all means please come over and say
hi not to me but to seven others others
it was all
and thank you very much for listening
thanks
[Applause]
thank you so much colin that was great
do you have any advice on where to find
some hackathons
in uh north america
not so many uh not so much uh
typically we one should
know would be my answer i think
you've caught me with that question i
suspect user groups would know so
if you're part of an r user group or a
data science user group
typically any hackathons would approach
the user group first of all for a bit of
advertising
so that's where i think you'd find and
once you once you sort of stumble into
that field
you then find them everywhere awesome
well thank you so much for uh joining us
from the uk we really appreciate it
so this concludes this track i believe
lunch is going to be served somewhere
out there
around 1 pm so thank you so much
you